what's up guys it's just steam today
we're gonna be making cake pops I've
made them before and I've basically
failed miserably but today we're gonna
be making them in this it's a cake pop
maker I got it on Amazon where I buy
everything I thought this seems
foolproof after doing a little bit of
research though most of the people
recommended not using boxed cakes with
this and when you make cake pops their
cake but they're also mixed with icing
so this is not gonna be the traditional
cake pops that's smashed up cake with
smashed up icing we're gonna be making a
special concoction that is I I don't
even know I found this recipe online so
to be honest with you I have no idea
what I'm doing cubes out out the
Munchkin time it's actually a super cute
little website this woman has their
little daughter baking everything so I
feel like if this small child can do it
there's a pretty good chance I'm
probably gonna fail at it but let's try
me what's the worst that can happen 3 to
follow her recipe let's get all of our
ingredients we're making this thing from
scratch apparently the cake box
consistency is a little bit too thin and
it doesn't make your cake pops for not
round I don't know a large mixing bowl
with butter sugar until light and creamy
okay well this is our butter it's
actually softened for once put you in
there
we've got our sugar nicely labeled
because I've got a labeling machine and
I love it and you go
honestly getting a mixer was the best
thing that I've ever done in my entire
life it does everything for me now watch
me mix now watch me - 11
one-to-one the out of time it perfectly
[Applause]
mix flour with salt and baking powder I
like salt all right I've got our milk
the other half I don't know why we do
that really this is our last step
three minutes
so far so good let's chase it oh my
sweet sweet batter oh yeah that's good
so here's our little thing so we're
gonna make the cake pops first and then
we're gonna decorate them I guess that's
how it works
how long I don't know anything about
this thing I dunno we need to spray it
cuz we don't want stuff getting stuck in
here okay so I was doing a little test
because I wanted it to be perfect on my
first try my house pretty dumb to me
[Applause]
I think we should get him out I think I
should get him out of here surprisingly
all I gotta do is just peel that crap
away and we might have a pretty solid
cake pop on our hands the heck look how
good this is
oh god it's really hot this was just
supposed to be like a little test they
look really good oh whoa jeez oh my god
my fingers are burning yeah my body is a
while Wonderland I'm body's a wonderland
Gees always let's do this again
basically when you guys while you were
away I just scooped a scoop into there
just like about so I definitely put too
much in that's for sure
closer up hey Google set a timer for
five minutes okay five minutes sorry now
I wonder what this tastes like
good it tastes really good swallow this
insanity has been happening I've been
over here melting some chocolates or
some can tallboy i drop some treats the
candies have been over there melting and
I've got this new one that I wanted to
try it's a pastel candy melt with
sprinkles in it I thought since it's
gonna be st. Patrick's Day and I don't
even know like the soonish that I would
do some st. Patrick's Day themed cake
pops he's up good I'm surprised I'm
super impressed look at this this is
melting up nice
oh yeah oh yeah these look good Wow so
hot so hot they're so hot you think I've
learned in the first time hmm Lee I'm
super impressed look at our balls look
at this little thing it's a little tiny
kpop tray I'm not sure if that's
actually gonna hold up so we're gonna do
a few of the white cake pops first that
a bunch of these little cake pop
popsicle sticks probably should've got
shorter ones these are cake pop minis
it's gonna be a little bit big but
that's alright
dunk in here stick it in our cake pop
dunk it in let's get him nice and
covered nice and covered it's a little
bit chunky I think I'm gonna like let
them sit a little bit come back I was
like slipping and sliding off the stick
[Music]
looking good this cake pop maker is
incredible
[Music]
his little stand is it gonna fall over
and I'm gonna ruin all my cake pops and
I'm gonna be severely upset happy st.
Patrick's Day
oh yeah these are gonna have to look
he's falling off it's okay little guy
I know you've seen better days
[Music]
it's kind of hard with some of them
they've got the real crispy little
corners here
[Music]
one last one for our collection
well here they are happy st. Patrick's
Day I'm pretty impressed there's a lot
of things that I could have done better
to improve them but overall I think they
look pretty fantastic so I want to taste
one because I've added to a taste test
so here we go
it's actually really incredible real
record I hope you guys enjoy this video
and to answer your question and my
question does the mini cake pop maker
work yes it works so well I saw a bunch
of other recipes online for things that
you can make in a cake pop maker that
aren't cake pops so I can't wait to try
some of those out there's like little
hot dogs there's all kinds of things my
life is changed forever forever from the
mini cake pop maker you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you hit like don't
forget to subscribe so you'll see future
videos and I will see you in the next
video there's also gonna be a little on
the screen that pops up here very very
shortly where you can watch my previous
video so check that out too see you
later so I'm gonna order a pizza right
now I'm not gonna touch my phone I don't
know if I get a notification like what
happens like how is it gonna know where
to get my pizza from we're gonna try hey
ready 1 2